uh judges  will choose if we have a tiebreaker  all right jalen green's got oh it's  another one  no no no no no no no no no no no no big  dunks in that is that like the flavor  flavor  that's an nft by the duck with an nft on  he's got it  just signed with coinbase a little bit  oh  that thing flies and hits you in your  face be careful that's all i'm saying  gold chain with the nft pendant he's  playing his own highlights  bringing this into the modern day okay  say no more all about to say he's not  dunking i think he's gonna just tuck it  on this jersey let's go who do you give  this to  isaiah yeah okay  eight to nine eight  there you go there you go oh just a  regular law but it works and green's got  one in the books gotta give them some  some eights and i get them seven seven  and eight yeah seven and eight  thirty nine or forty  look at shaq  this is